ورائي الآن قد وقع للتو في ما يجب
أن يكون بالتأكيد انفجارًا كبيرًا
لم نكن نسمع فيه الطائرات في
اللحظات القليلة الماضية ، لذا قد يكون هذا واحدًا
من عدد من السيارات المفخخة ، لذا
كان داعش ينتشر في محاولته للمحاولة
والاحتفاظ  البشمركة خارج هذا الطريق هي
حالة متقلبة وهي أيضًا حالة
يبدو فيها أن البشمركة سائدة في هذه المرحلة
حيث اتخذوا هذا
الامتداد الذي يبلغ طوله خمسة أو ستة كيلومترات من الطريق
هنا ولكن القرى المحيطة به لا
تزال متقلبة  هذا هو السؤال
عن نوع المقاومة التي
سيستمرون في مواجهة الجيش العراقي عليها
في وقت ما يجب أن يدفعوا إلى الأسفل
هنا نحو الموصل ، لكن هذا كان
جهدًا يحظى بدعم دولي كبير ، وقد
أتى الكثير من قوات التحالف لتخطيط القوة الجوية الأمريكية.  ما الذي
يطلقون عليه دعنا نتحرك ، نعم